anytime i was having a bad day i'd just
go sit in town's room and watch him play
games all day
pretty simple and he could just it pure
enjoy
a game like a little kid does you know
like i just wanted to watch him play all
my childhood games and i
i it like gave me this treasure feel
treasured feeling that i can't even
explain twitch streamer byron reckful
bernstein has died according to multiple
reports
he was 31 years old while exact details
about his death have not been revealed
news first broke after his ex-girlfriend
seemingly tweeted about him writing
quote
someone i loved killed themselves i wish
i could have said something to prevent
it
she also shared a video of her with
reckful adding quote
byron i wish i could have helped you we
all do
reckful a former esports player was one
of the first streamers on twitch
and had hundreds of thousands of
followers
now tributes have been pouring in all
across the gaming community
fellow twitch streamer lyric wrote that
he was absolutely floored by the news
adding that reckful is and will always
be an absolute legend
content creator jack courage dunlop said
reckful's death is a terrible tragedy
while osman gold posted that he hopes
reckful's death
is a wake-up call to everyone who
creates reward structure around
ridiculing and mocking mental illness
adding that we can be better as a
community
fans of reckful became worried about his
well-being following a series of
messages he posted on twitter thursday
he wrote i feel bad for anyone who has
to deal with my insanity
please just know in these situations the
insane person does not feel in control
of their actions
reckful had reportedly proposed to
another one of his ex-girlfriends on
twitter
hours before his death
you